shouldn't raise your children to believe
that they can be beyonce because the
chances are they can't
wilstar is an award-winning author of
six critically acclaimed books his ideas
are disruptive challenging and
life-changing and some of them will make
you feel incredibly uncomfortable people
don't like to talk about this stuff
ninety-nine percent of self-help works
never mention genes they want to promote
that idea of well i can be whoever they
want to be but a huge amount of who we
are is who we were born as that myth of
you have full control over yourself as a
human being that's the problem it's not
about embracing your flaws it's about
accepting your flaws
our lives are full of status pursue the
more status that you earn the better
everything else gets that was true ten
thousand years ago it's true today the
brain is highly attuned to where we sit
in a pecking order the lower we are down
in that pecking order the more unhealthy
we became if you take two smokers the
one higher up is less likely to have a
smoking-related disease than the one
lower down that's mental it matters
massively
how do we advance in the status game
that there are kind of three general
types of status games we can play
first game is a
without further ado i'm stephen bartlett
and this is the diary of a ceo i hope
nobody's listening but if you are then
please keep this to yourself
[Music]
will first of all thank you for being
here um
take me right back then to your early
years because i think when i was reading
through your different books here
throughout them you have glimpses of
your own perspective and it hints back
to what i read about your your early
years um so take me back right back to
the start you know before the age of
let's say 12.
okay so
yeah um
i was brought up in tumblr 12s in kent
um
middle-class family very catholic um it
was quite a
victorian um
strict
superstitious religious upbringing not
the happiest
upbringing i have to say why um because
my parents were very strict my father
was very strict especially
um and
they were very
much in the grip of the
catholic belief system which i just
didn't
never like always baffled me even as a
kid like what ha ha
how can you believe
this stuff and i went to a catholic
school so so and i was quite uh i was
probably difficult if you were to ask
them they'd say i was a difficult child
um because i was pushing against that
all the time you know i thought it was
crazy i wasn't very good at authority
and rules so it was a bad fit i would
say um and i think that's what's you
know one of the things that that's kind
of driven
my interests into adulthood my you know
my my second book the heretics was
looking at
why do otherwise smart people believe
end up leaving these crazy things
because my parents are smart people
but um
yeah you know they believe in heaven
hell satan all of that stuff
i i think that's how my childhood has
informed my interests as an adult trying
to figure out
how how that happens
in your in your book selfie you you talk
a lot about self-esteem
and the role that plays what was your
give me the context of yours how your
self-esteem was shaped in those early
years
oh well um how it was shaped in its
early years i guess it was
poorly would be the answer
um i think
the
you know because
my behavior was not great the
continual message i would get from
teachers and parents was that you're
you know you're a bad person you're
going to end up in prison you're going
to end up in care
um
uh
yeah so
so there was very little kind of
positive feedback in my
in my childhood which i think is
that that causes damage that you're
never going to get over i i believe
do you think you never get over that
damage
yes because i think you know we're all
born with a certain kind of personality
with a certain genome
and that that's not fate that doesn't
define who you're going to be forever um
but but it sets you on a certain course
it makes you vulnerable to a certain
kind of mindset
um and you know i think a good childhood
a good upbringing can
you know correct that to a certain
degree but a bad one can can set it on a
sort of negative course and i'm quite a
neurotic
person i'm anxious i've always worried a
lot so so when you take that kind of
natural
personality type high neuroticism and
add into that a
childhood which kind of reinforces that
sense that
the world is dangerous that people are
out to get you all of that stuff that
the the the reality isn't safe i i i and
then you know what happens is your brain
is still being formed
really up until you're in your mid-20s
you know that it's in your mid-20s when
when they when those kind of learning
processes
um
stop and so it's very hard and probably
i would argue probably impossible to
reverse
18 years of
that kind of
feedback
once it's happened because that's those
are the years in which your brain is
learning how the world works and and so
yeah so i i don't think it's fixable
that's one of the the ongoing um
conversations or debates or things that
i've kind of been chewing over from
doing this podcast and listening to
people from all walks of life that have
achieved amazing things that still have
um underlying trauma or sort of self
stories that are controlling their
their their life and their behavior and
i i spent a long time talking to people
about whether you can ever truly
eradicate some of these traumas they're
like the puppet master that's in the
back room controlling your
your biases and all these things and my
conclusion over the last literally weeks
has been that we can diminish the power
that our early traumas have over us but
they're always going to be there
and is that is that where you find find
yourself but in terms of your belief
that we can diminish the power of yeah
those stories but they'll always be
there
absolutely that's exactly right that's
what i believe exactly yeah we can
definitely diminish their power
and i i you know i'm 47 now and it still
amazes me that
you still you never stop learning and
you never stop learning about yourself
you never stop learning about things you
get wrong and i've got to stop doing
that you know it's overly simplistic to
think of consciousness as this battle
between reason and emotion
um uh but but there is something like
that going on you know like our
emotionality is usually in charge of
what we're thinking and what we're doing
you know we respond emotionally and that
voice in your head then tells a story
about what you're feeling and usually
it's to justify that emotion it's to say
yes you were right to feel like that you
were right to respond in anger and
hostility at that person and then the
next day you think oh maybe it wasn't
you know
you know so so um i think what we call
what we used to call reason that
reasonable voice in your head actually
often isn't reasonable it's just
justifying
and um validating your initial emotional
response which is you know sometimes
right sometimes wrong so so i think what
what you're doing when you're learning
for me anyways is your learning actually
really i mean almost a parent yourself
to turn that voice in your head into a
someone that isn't going to be a harsh
judge or
on the other extreme someone who's just
going to accept and validate and defend
everything every behavior you do every
thought you have every mistake you met
you make you're looking for that that
balance all the time and you're looking
to spot
i think you're looking to spot those
occasions on which you're making the
same mistake over and over again you
know have you got a harsh judge in your
head
absolutely yeah yeah definitely yeah i
have i i you know i'm so i'm
self-employed i've been a i've been a
writer for you know without an employer
for 20 years you you kind of i think you
have to have a harsh judge
to get yourself out of bed to get
yourself in front of the computer to do
eight hours plus work a day um
so i think to it's kind of weird i think
i think to achieve any anything
significant you've got to there's got to
be a harsh
harshness to i'm just trying to think
where the judge is the right
right word like i've read recently that
the ideal parent is kind of firm but
also kind and caring and understanding
and i think that's what
i think that's if that's the ideal
parent i think that's really that that's
that's the idea of who should be inside
our own heads really you have that
balance
um and i think you can go you can go
wrong
in either direction
your book selfie yeah um what was the
i mean i love the name it was very of
the time in 2017 it was yeah
um what was the inspiration behind
writing this book
right so the book before that was called
the heretics and the heretics was as it
says before it was kind of inspired by
this idea of what how do smart people
end up believing
crazy things and so that that but was
all about when we have these stubborn
beliefs that kind of that that are
irrational that we don't let go of so i
was hanging out with holocaust deniers i
was hanging out with creationists ufo
believers and people like this
um and then
in the promotion for that i was asked
again and again and again by people so
what makes people change their minds
you're saying that people can never
change their minds and i didn't have an
answer to that question i was going to
have to bluff through it so i thought
that's no
i don't understand that so
um maybe i should try and find out so i
was a journalist at the time as a day
job
and so i started interviewing lots of
people who changed their minds like in
big dramatic kind of powerful ways
one of those guys
was this amazing psychologist called
professor roy baumeister
he spent his kind of early professional
career in the self-esteem era of the 80s
you know when and this is the era i was
brought up to when everything was about
self-esteem it was all about that the
kind of message out there was if you
want to be successful just love yourself
you're amazing you're fantastic you can
do anything that you want you know it's
whitney houston um the greatest love of
all is yourself it was it was that kind
of era and i remember it from school i
remember like you know teachers saying
to me the problem with you will is you
just have low self-esteem and they
always got self-esteem a social vaccine
and if you if you loved yourself it
would meant that you would be more
successful you'd be happier you'd have a
better marriage and you know
in america they thought the self-esteem
was going to solve homelessness
um
gang culture
teenage parenthood was a big moral panic
of the time they thought was going to
cure that and he was like well is it
true is this actually true and so they
looked into it and they found actually
that there was no evidence that any of
this was true that every study that
quoted
it as being true just referenced another
study and you went in this breadcrumb
trail of studies they were all just
quoting each other and there was no
actual evidence any of this is true and
they just did they actually tested to
see whether that self-esteem myth was
true or not
um and it wasn't um it wasn't true um it
was it was originally based on this idea
that they this this observation that um
school children who did well in exams
also had high self-esteem so they
assumed that having high self-esteem
made you good at exams but actually they
had high self-esteem because they'd done
good in their exams it was it was the
other way around because it's obvious in
retrospect but that's what you know so
that that was the error they made
correlation causation that old chestnut
um so so he um um published this study
and the initial response was just you
know it was absolutely torn to pieces
um he was either ignored or attacked um
but slowly he was proven to be right and
so when i was i i wrote a profile of
baumeister and um
you know he was a fascinating guy and
then what i realized was that this idea
had um
not just changed a person but it changed
the culture
like the whole culture of the west
britain america canada and lots of
europe
when i was growing up in the eighties
and nineties we were just obsessed with
this idea and it just was just wrong
because it's completely wrong so that
was the that's the heart of selfies like
this this idea of you know
how did selfie culture happen how did we
become so self-obsessed and the
self-esteem movement is was a big part
of that story and it's the kind of
is that it's the kind of central story
of the book chapter zero yeah um the
dying self
was a was quite difficult to read ah
okay yeah i thought it was a very um you
know you explore topics like suicide and
um
your own sort of self-doubt and things
like that and
um your own
suicidal ideation at times
why why did you choose to start the book
in that way
i suppose i wanted to start the book
there
to show
you know why this matters you know
where i ended up with in the book was
this idea that we live that we are in
the west
individualists yeah you know we see the
world as made up of individual pieces
and parts and we are individually
responsible for our fates we're
individually responsible for our success
and our failure and there's lots of good
things to say about that you know it's
an extremely motivating way of
organizing your thoughts organizing your
life
um you know i am responsible for me and
and i will take care of me um but it's
also kind of savage you know and um i it
it means you know that that kind of
western myth we have
is that um
you know that you can do anything that
you want just put your mind to it you
can achieve it that that kind of mindset
um but but very often we fail
and so if it's true that you're
responsible for your success then it
only logically follows that you're also
responsible for your failure um and so
um
these individualistic ideas accelerated
in the 1980s and that's because of a
variety of things it was the self-esteem
movement partly but the self-esteem move
became successful because we because of
the thatcher reagan revolution is my
argument neoliberalism that we changed
the economies of the west we changed the
game you know before the 1980s were much
more collective it was much more
um you know socialist even in america
the top rate of tax was 90 percent you
know it's extraordinary uh um so
and then the economy started going wrong
in the 70s so
the neoliberal revolution happened and
the idea the central idea that you know
reagan and thatcher pursued was we're
going to increase competition wherever
we can to reduce the social safety net
privatise everything just everyone's got
to be competitive and it changed who we
are you know it when you change the
rules of the game of life you change the
people who play that game which is what
my latest book is about really
and so we became more um competitive as
a people and and what's what
psychologists find is a major study that
found
that since um the you know the onset of
neoliberalism levels of perfectionism
have increased massively in the uk in
america
and in canada uh and um perfectionism is
implicated in suicidal ideation in
eating disorders in steroid abuse and
you know and self-harm and so on and so
on and so on so so that's why i wanted
to begin the book theory to show why
this matters you know this
isn't just a kind of abstract academic
exploration of the self
you know i wanted to begin with this is
how it affects people
if perfectionism can be quite an
insidious um
issue in western cultures where we're
getting more individualistic what is a
better approach do you think to take for
what is a better message to share with
society in the world about
um about that
um
i think
you know i like the idea of you know i
think the idea that i kind of develop is
in selfie partly it's about
self-acceptance rather than self-love i
think
self-love um is that
you know i used to be a massive fan of
big brother i wouldn't be brother
and there was always a thing in big
brother where um somebody would behave
completely obnoxiously they'd be like
rude aggressive just deeply unpleasant
and they would always defend themselves
in the same way they go well i'm just
being me that's just me and if you don't
like me
you know and i think that's that's the
self-esteem movement talking it's like
i'm my i'm gonna be my authentic self
and if you can't handle that that's on
you and i think that's wrong you know
you know we're a social animal we've
we have evolved to exist cooperatively
and i think when individualism i think
there's a lot to say in its defense but
when it goes too far that's where it
becomes it becomes that kind of screw
you
um mindset so i think self-acceptance is
different than self-love self-acceptance
is i'm flawed broken animal
you know as we all are and
you know i i like what we're talking
about earlier on it's about being that
harsh but loving parent rather than that
rather than being your own defense
lawyer you know being being that kind of
harsh but loving parent and being
accepted you know having this acceptance
that you are a flawed and limited
animal
like
you know
you shouldn't raise your children to
believe that they can be beyonce if they
want to be beyonce because the chances
are they can't she's like an
extraordinarily talented and driven
individual she's the one in a billion
you know so uh
you know
so i think that's an unhealthy message
to by which to raise our children and
also you know talk to ourselves and it's
much more about understanding our our
strengths our flaws and kind of finding
the right games to play to find out that
little corner of the world in which we
can feel
um of value i think that's that's what
we should be trying to do
had your parents told you that you were
beyonce and had those schools told you
that you were beyonce
would you have been happier do you think
um
i mean i was sometimes told that that i
could succeed at school but i just
wasn't applying myself and it's such a
waste it's such a waste yeah
um
but it's so weird the school thing i i
mean i have to say i think i went to a
really bad school
um
it was a comprehensive school um
you know you hear these stories about
teachers that inspire you and it wasn't
for this teacher i never had that
teacher they were all just really bored
and resentful i remember
one
minutes and that would be the history
lesson you know and that was the school
i went to it was miserable and i and i'm
i always wanted to be a writer
and i was always in trouble i was always
this sort of problem student and i had
this english teacher was quite nice
called mr lanaway and i thought oh you
know i'm going to write start writing
short stories in my spare time and i'm
going to give them to my english teacher
it's just a way of getting a look and
i've written this thing and so i gave
him a couple and i think i gave him
number three uh you know after on a
third weekend thinking that that he was
oh in my head he was thinking oh will's
you know william has found this thing
that he's actually applying himself to
how amazing and he said to me
you know this is all just extra work for
me don't you like that so he kind of
scolded me for giving him extra work to
do so i stopped i stopped writing those
you know short stories
and i just think if i if i if i'd have
actually been encouraged to be i was
never encouraged to be a writer by
my school or you know i i wrote a school
magazine and that that caused me all
kinds of trouble as well
so so i never actually had any
encouragement and i i do kind of think
if i was actually encouraged
um
to be a writer i would have probably got
there sooner and probably been a better
writer today well on that point of
beyonce though it seems to me that if
someone had turned around to you and
said you you are beyonce you can do
anything you could be an amazing writer
it seems to me that that actually might
have helped
yes yeah yes but but that's what i mean
about identifying your strengths like i
think for me writing was a strength but
nobody ever
and if that was identified
and if somebody said to me god you know
you should carry on right and
literally if one person one adult said
to me these short stories are you know
they share real problems you should
carry on writing these it would have
blown my mind that i'd have definitely
carried on um but i just stopped you
know i just stopped er
so yeah but that's what i mean i think
the mistake is
um somebody you know in the research for
selfie this harvard psychologist brian
little said it's the myth of
unlimited control that myth of
you can you can you know you have full
control over your yourself as a human
being and that means that you can do
anything that's the problem you know
that's the problem and but actually i
think what what you should do is
identify what is this person
passionate about you know and what
actually what they actually good at and
if and if and if and if somebody saw
promise in me as a journalist or a
writer then that that's what they they
should have encouraged me in but it was
actually just a battle
in um in the in the chapter the good
self in that book chapter four you talk
about um the different forces that are
controlling our behavior
and uh it made me think i've you know
that i've also had this this ongoing
thought about how control of
of my life i
over what the forces are that are
actually controlling my life because we
tend to believe obviously as we would
from this first person view that i'm
making my decisions
but when i
it sounds quite i don't care i'm gonna
say it
when i reflect on the stories i've heard
from men
regarding
their behavior
before they've ejaculated and after
they've ejaculated
it is pretty it's and i actually said
this in like podcast number four when no
one was actually listening and it was
just me and under the stairs in
manchester i said the change that i saw
in my behavior or how i felt before and
after ejaculation is extreme yeah and i
watched rogan talk about this he
described it as being
before ejaculation at the back of the
bus
and you're just [ __ ] being swung
around he said it's foggy there's papers
everywhere and then and then he says
post ejaculation it's like you zoom
forward onto the wheel of the bus and go
[ __ ] what was going on
and you gained back control yeah and
just this um it for me that was one of
the clearest signs
that my decision-making as is not as
intentional as i thought it was yeah
um
and you talk about that kind of thing a
little bit in that chapter do you talk
about a study where um men are
asked um a variety of different
questions while they're masturbating
can you can you share that study and
also like what you learned from it about
the way that we make our decisions
well i haven't
that was i haven't
read about that study for a good five
years now but i think it was something
about
they were asked a series of questions
about
um
what were they our series of questions
about what they would do in certain yeah
it's like the sexual preferences right
yeah would you would you be attracted to
an animal would you be absolutely yeah
yeah
yeah and i think before they'd
masturbated their their answers were
much more extreme in the direction of
yes i would have sex with an animal yes
i would pressure somebody into having
sex than they would after
um masturbation and i think most men can
can read that study and go
you can relate a little bit to not not
that i'm saying that you know most men
would have sex with an animal obviously
but but but how are how are um
how our thinking is different and and
and you know i i i love studies like
that because i feel like it
you know when we when we when we feel a
different way we do almost become a
different person like i'm writing in
selfie about
um you know when i'm trying to lose
weight again
and on monday morning i'm absolutely
resolute it's like
i'm gonna
keep my calories down i'm going to
exercise every day i am a machine i'm a
stoic i'm athletic you know that's who i
am but by friday evening i'm just like
oh sorry i'm going to give it a go i
need to have some chips you know and
it's like it's not just that you feel a
different way
it's almost you've become a different
person but which i mean you have a
different personality you're much more
loose and happy and good to be around on
friday than you're on monday when you're
like that
but you have a different value system
on monday i value this set of things i
value discipline and order and structure
and on friday evening i value fun and
laughter and pleasure so it's so so it
is that we almost
you know i think pre and post
ejaculation we almost become a different
person monday monday morning versus
friday night we become different people
so i think that you know we're so fluid
in
in who we are depending on how we're
feeling we don't want to be though no
it's not how we think of ourselves we
think of ourselves as a yeah a certain
kind of person yeah with as a certain
boxed in set of values and
behaviors i think you know there's
probably
somewhere above 50 of people listening
that can relate to that monday issue of
you know on monday i am you know a greek
god and i am
disciplined and i am everything i'll
become everything i want to be on by you
know by next week
um and then something happens how does
i would be remiss if i didn't ask
what can you tell us about how to stop
or how to maintain or be consistent
as our monday selves is there anything
you've learned
about the psychology there that might
help us to be our monday selves come
friday
so in in selfie i write about um how
important it is to change our
environment rather than trying rather
than change try and change ourselves
and and the kind of exact the kind of
story that i tell is i call it the
lizard and the iceberg where if you take
a lizard from the desert and pop it on
an iceberg it's going to be a very
unhappy lizard if you put it back in the
desert it's going to be
happy and thriving and wonderful and
nothing has changed in the lizard it's
the environment that's changed and i and
i think part of being an individualist
and we is that we look into it into
ourselves to our behavior to
um explain the causes of our behavior
but actually you know so much of
of um
of our behavior is controlled by what's
going on around us by our environment
you know and the reason we feel you know
friday on fridays because because it's
friday and that has the cultural
resonance so it's friday night yeah i
think thank [ __ ] it's friday and i'm
going on five days of work we feel
different um so so i think a lot of it
is about changing your environment you
know
there is a lot to say about you know if
you take yourself to the gym you've
changed your environment
um if you um
if you can
certainly with things like weight loss
i mean it's a lesson that i never seem
to learn but do not have that stuff in
the house
guarantee that you will eat it um you
know it's it's it's a drug uh and and so
so i think
i i think
maintain your environment to maintain
yourself you know i i think that's that
that's one of the one of the key
takeaways that i've learned
how to stay alive in the age of
perfectionism
how does one stay alive one of the
interesting things in that chapter was
um you kind of debunk this idea that
alcoholism for example and a lot of
these things you know that i've spoken
to guests about on this podcast that
they've suffered with um don't
necessarily stem from having a unhappy
childhood i've got a friend that you
know is very public about the fact that
he became an alcoholic and um i i guess
i believed it was because of
traumatic early events i tended to
believe that that was the case but you
debunked that quite clearly
um
and and kind of assert that personality
is the causal factor in in most of our
predispositions yeah i i think one of
the things that i've that i've learned
um
well certainly from research in that
book was just the incredible power of
personality and the incredible power of
of our genes
um it's really people don't like to talk
about this stuff and because it it it
they feel it's disempowering so whenever
you read a self-help book
most of them 99 of self-help books never
mention genes because it's unhelpful
they want to promote that idea of 100
self-control i can be whoever i want to
be um but but but genes are so important
and as i said it's not that they did
dictate who we are or you know or um
you're you're born with a kind of
blueprint and that's all you're ever
going to be
um
but you are born
with a certain kind of genome you know
with a certain level of
likely neuroticism
openness to experience extroversion um
agreeableness you know how how kind of
happy or kind of angry and competitive
you are and so on
and so you're born kind of with a
certain prevailing wind and then your
childhood experiences mostly um will
um do the rest of that wiring up so by
the time you're in in your kind of 20s
you're kind of who you are like not 100
because still traumatic experiences can
break you to pieces you know
you know
lots of things can change but you're
kind of who you are
as i said p you know people don't like
that idea because it really goes against
our individualist kind of credo of you
can be beyonce if you want to be
but it is nevertheless true that a huge
amount of who we are is just how we were
who who we were born as
you know and i've got that addictive
personality i was an alcoholic i haven't
i'd had to give up drink when i was 26
because i'd lost control of how much i
was drinking and i still struggle with
kind of you know sugar now i i've
swapped booze for sugar as is my
problematic behavior which is much
easier to manage um so so i get it and
and but but yeah it's it's not it's i i
think part the fact that with these
storytelling animals um
i think
since 70s since it's probably this well
even the 60s we've had this kind of
therapy culture which wants to go
archaeological digging in our past for
the causes of our
um
all of our problems and you know i i
think there's
there is a certain amount of
um truth to that stuff like i i'm sure
our childhoods affect us
um but but um there are we we tend to
blame everything on our childhoods
everything on our parents and i think
alcoholism is one of those things that
it's mostly genetic you know you've
either got that problem with
addiction or you don't
could it can can it be accelerated by
trauma though because you know when i
when i speak to psychologists they often
talk about it being a form of escapism
um in many ways and other drugs and you
know other self-medications being a form
of like trying to escape pain or trauma
definitely yeah i i think how to think
about it is that it's um
you could have a vulnerability to it
yeah um and that's the genetic component
um and if something bad happens to you
then you're much more likely to kind of
fall into that dress as someone else
who doesn't yeah exactly yeah okay yeah
on that point of storytelling you
mentioned storytelling there in our um
in our narrative your book in 2019 was
about storytelling i having worked in
marketing was very compelled to read
this book for the probably you know we
talked before we start recording that a
lot of people will see a book about with
the word storytelling on the front of it
and think that they can use it from a
marketing capacity or in a business
sense
what have you learned
about
how people can tell great stories in the
context of business and marketing
yeah well um so quite quite a lot i
teach uh i teach business storytelling
at section four which is a american ed
tech um uh organization so so i do a a a
course there on in the science of
storytelling for business
um and and
you know we are storytelling animals we
we we think in story we we um you know
narrative is basically
you know
how we experience ourselves and and life
and so
as i say in that course if you're not
communicating with story as a marketeer
you you're not communicating you know
logic and facts and data and statistics
that's not the language of the brain the
language of the brain is beginning
middle and end a character overcoming
obstacles i think a lot of the stuff
we've been talking about is important um
especially
the idea that people think with their
feelings you know it's feelings first
story second the story justifies the
feelings and so if you want to
tell persuasive stories you need to
first understand exactly who you're
communicating with and you need to
understand um how they feel about the
world how they feel about themselves how
they feel about
um
you know justice and uh what their
values are and so that means
understanding them kind of tribally what
groups do they belong to who are the
heroes who are their villains
what motivates them what demotivates
them so so before you can sort of write
the story you need to figure out how
they feel about the world
so a bad story then would be one that
was because you know i thought about
this a lot and my previous business was
um very successful in storytelling so my
first company's social chain it's grown
to be a very big business maybe a
thousand employees worldwide
we were um we started out as a marketing
agency never had a sales team
because we we focused on telling stories
those stories were told on social media
and on stage by me so when i would go up
on stage and talk about our agency to
try and win business from apple or
coca-cola whoever it was um i would
actually start by talking about my
relationship with my mother
and that would be the first sentences
out of my mouth when i walked on stage
if there was a thousand people or 15 000
people there it would be about my mother
and through that story about my mother
and my and my upbringing and my battles
and all those things eventually you
learn about our business and what we do
and about the great work we do but that
was the preface of it and
that meant we never needed a
sales team
i've always believed that
if i'd walked on stage and started with
a case study yes
i
i think this is one of the biggest
mistakes businesses make when they pitch
when they when they speak on stage when
they post on social media i think they
have a
they believe that the the listener wants
big numbers and to how many views they
got for their clients or
yeah and it just doesn't seem to be
consistent with reality no it's not i
mean so what you're doing when you're
going through with your mother is you're
connecting emotionally
so people are
you know wanting they're on your side
immediately and you're making them feel
good you're making them feel things
emotionally um the the kind of framework
that i use for business storytelling is
that is that is that you know
essentially
people's brains process reality
um in the same way and that's the you
know so they're the hero of their story
you're not the hero standing on the
stage the company that that's telling
you isn't the hero they're the hero of
their own story
um they are you know that they've got
goals they're trying to pursue we all
have you know that which are the plots
of our lives the audience yeah the
audience the person you're selling to um
and then
there's a brilliant story analyst called
christopher booker who wrote this
amazing book called the seven basic
plots
and he writes about
archetypal characters in storytelling
that he calls light figures and so the
light figure is uh the example he uses
are the three ghosts in the christmas
carol the charles dickens scrooge story
so scrooge is the hero of that story
but the three ghosts come in to show him
christmas past christmas present
christmas future they help him get what
he needs which is to become a better
more selfless more generous more loving
giving person that so that they are
going to they arrive in his story to
kind of show him the way to help him get
what he needs and so that that that's
what i argue that's the appropriate
position for most companies and
organizations and leaders is not to be
the hero because your audience feels
like they're the hero you're the light
figure you're there to help them get
what they want so when you go straight
in with his or my awards here's what
this person said about me here's some
statistics and stuff you're not a light
figure you're presenting as the hero
what people really want to know is how
can you help me get what i want and and
that's that's the story that you have to
tell what kind of example can you give
me to really make that
make me understand that in a real
practical sense is there a brand you've
seen do this really well is there an
example of
a i mean i my brain went to nike for
some reason yeah yeah well that's oh and
nike's really interesting example so
so obviously one of the things that nike
has done recently is it's um
done the ad campaign around colin
kaepernick which is you know
controversial but did them i think i
think that something was like six
percent like uh after that that ad
campaign
and that's a really good example of um
an organization who is um um
behaving as a light figure so that colin
kaepernick campaign has nothing to do
with shoes there's you know what they're
not doing is going our shoes will make
you run eight percent faster we've got
these sprung souls we've got these
amazing laces that won't trip you up or
whatever you know their stats list
there's not in there
it's purely they're telling a story
they've figured out that their client
base are mostly believing cert you know
this set of
beliefs around the world uh and and
there's those are goals you know people
who you know the the target audience
that they're um
they're
appealing to want to achieve this kind
of racial social justice and that's
important to them so so what nike are
basically saying is you know we are
light figures in this story you know we
we are we we are on the side of the
colin kaepernicks of the people who are
kneeling you know we believe that black
lives matter um and and so they're
presenting as a light figure and if you
think about it rationally it's kind of
crazy like why would a shoe company have
this political thing but it's because of
the storytelling because because they're
presenting as a light figure who who is
engaged in the kind of
you know this particular mission the
world
and you know in in order to kind of to
to to kind of join the mission
you you buy the nike shoes and and it
and it worked you know it works really
well i mean
one of the archetypal examples um that i
talk about that i love is that there was
a
an ad that was broadcast i think it was
in the 60s by volkswagen and it was the
first kind of modern ad advert the first
it was the first advert that you would
look at and recognize as
the kind of advertising that we do today
so before this volkswagen ad um
you know all ads were just stats lists
here's this amazing you know tire and
you know this will get you naughty 60
and whatever um and then this volkswagen
did this amazing ad where um it just it
was black and white because it was still
in the days of black and white and they
had um it just showed this guy it was
all snow into a big blizzard outside
and this guy gets in his car he turns
he's like it's like you know just before
dawn turns in his ignition drives his
car through the blizzard
the blizzard opens these huge shed doors
and then you hear this big engine start
up and outdrives his snowplow and it's
how does the guy
who drives the snowplow get to the
snowplow and it's just volkswagen and
that's a really simple really effective
story and it's showing volkswagen as
this light figure we are helping the
hero achieve what he wants and you know
i don't believe that the volkswagen was
particularly good at driving through
blizzards
i don't believe that like and they
certainly weren't making any factual
claim in the sense that we are better
than land rover and whatever whatever
whatever doing this because of this stat
it was as simple as that and it
revolutionized marketing it changed
everything because they'd figured out
that kind of light figure
form of storytelling and in that are
they saying that the volkswagen
volkswagen enables you to be the hero
exactly yeah nike are saying that the
nike shoe
associated with colin kaepernick enables
you to be
the
social activist hero exactly yeah colin
kaepernick was yeah exactly yeah yeah
fascinating it's gonna change a few
things about my uh few of my companies i
think the basis of that yeah i think i
think we i think in the course of
business we all forget that emotion is
the most important thing i'm thinking
about all the newsletters that my
companies have been writing i've got
various companies and the newsletters
they write and the videos we make and
how
and how sometimes we
we think that facts and figures and
information is what the viewer is
looking for in their lives but the most
compelling way to draw them in to
whatever we're doing whether it's a
newsletter or a tweet or whatever is by
putting emotion first and really yeah
what the emotion of the content is yeah
yeah exactly and with that with the nike
example i mean
we live in since the global entry crisis
we live in heightened political times
and so so you know and people are always
tribal
and and so you know one of the big
things that that the successful kind of
persuaders do is is to make those tribal
appeals
um and you know sometimes it works with
colin kaepernick like with the gillette
razor campaign it didn't work because
you were kind of essentially attacking
your target audience um
so that was you know less successful um
i think there was a terrible pepsi ad
with kendall jenner
where where
where where they were kind of basically
yeah we were just making this yeah well
it put a super rich uh beautiful model
white woman as the uh the hero
against social injustice and drinking
this sugary drink is gonna help yeah you
know so it's just all off yeah so so i
think organizations are sensing that
partly how we can be a light figure
these days is by is by
presenting as people who are assisting
in these
th these political goals have become
very important to people especially
young people um and some people are
getting it right some people are getting
it wrong there's a real science to it
though isn't there yeah more we've
spoken i've realized how how there is a
science to it when you understand the
the roles and also the audience the
roles of the characters in your content
or your piece and also where the it's
really about where the audience sees
themselves yeah
yeah and how they feel represented
as you probably know vodafone are one of
our amazing sponsors on this podcast if
you're a small business owner listening
right now this tip is for you the only
constant in business as you'll probably
know if you run a business is change
your business your team and your company
culture need to be designed to embrace
and welcome change when the world
changes without you change resistant
businesses and teams often get left
behind and that's why i've partnered
with vodafone business and their vhub to
help small businesses access the
knowledge they need to embed that
philosophy into their companies a
philosophy of change the v-hub has
completely free resources tips insights
and expert one-on-one vhub digital
advisors to chat with you so you can
stay at the very forefront of change
search vhub by vodafone now
your 2021 book the status game this is
the book that when i was reading through
all of my notes i have by far the most
amount of notes on right because maybe
it's just you know
the way i'm compelled or whatever but it
was really really fascinating and very
felt very relevant
status as a topic
why why does status matter and what is
status for people that don't understand
the word
okay so so so it matters massively and
and the reason i wanted to write that
book is because
people just don't really talk about it
very much
even though
our lives are full of status but people
just don't talk about it very much
status or status well americans say
status brits tend to say status but i
guess it's both yeah it's both um uh so
so i i think one of the one of the one
other one of the kind of
reasons people kind of tend to not like
this subject
is that when i when i sort of make the
argument that we're all motivated by
status pursue that kind of thing i think
i'm saying we all want to be rich we all
want to be famous and that's not what
i'm saying at all what i'm saying is
that we all want to feel of value
so we evolved as these you know tribal
animals and to be successful in the
tribe means two things you've got to be
good at connecting with other people so
so being accepted and and influencing a
sense of belongingness with other people
so that's belongingness that's
connection that's not stated that's
something else
um
but once we're in a group in a tribe we
want to rise within it we want to feel
like we are of value to other people and
so back in the days when our brains are
evolving in the in you know when we're
living in the in the tribes um
the more status that you earned uh the
more and better food you'd get the safer
your sleeping sites the safer your
children would be the greater your
access to your choice of mates so i mean
as we all know surviving reproduction
are the basic most fundamental um drives
we have
as living things
and status when you rise in status your
chances of survival and reproduction
just go up and up and up and up so when
you're in the tribes the most you know
people would try and get status in the
tribes um and and the more
more status you got the better
everything else became and so that was
true
ten thousand years ago it's true today
that is still true today the more status
that you earn the better everything else
gets so it's this huge um
huge component of
human behavior but it's subconscious so
we don't like to think about it
sometimes we like to deny it even though
we
all
love to feel of value and we are all
very very sensitive to any indication
that we that somebody considers us to be
of lesser value
you know you said at the start of that
when you introduce this topic people
will have kind of an allergic reaction
because they think they think you mean
and it goes back to what we were saying
about your audience receiving that
message
in a bad way because of where it frames
them it frames them as being kind of
narcissistic and
selfish and you know and those are no
nobody wants to admit that they they are
selfish or they are you know they're
concerned with status they don't admit
it it's true
but no one wants to say i'll say it
it's just the way that we are um
um
but and then you went on to say that you
know people don't like to admit they
want to be famous but i tend to believe
that a lot of people do want to be
famous and in that book you talk about
children in particular when they're
asked what they want to be when they're
older
it's quite pretty alarming right yeah i
mean and that's i mean that's that's
again an indicator of the rise in
individualism uh that that's the the
more and more kids in the west since the
levant has been saying we want to be
rich you want to be famous but there are
all kinds of status games that we can
play and i think i think the
i i think the the one of the important
things to understand about status games
is is that the brain is so obsessed with
status
it it assigns kind of status points to
consent to anything so for so for some
people for lots of people the accrual of
money that's their status game that's
how they're measuring their status how
much money i've got but for other people
for it it can be
um how simply i live you know i i i know
someone who
um he's a lovely guy but he considers
himself to be sort of not materialistic
and he's very much in the wellness space
and he um
you know was telling me um last year
that he's you know he takes his kids to
their private school but the school
gates you know he's got this beaten up
old car that he's had since he was a
student and he's got masking tape around
the
[Music]
the the the wing mirror and he was sort
of talking oh you know all the other
parents have got these big mercedes and
audis and vmws but i've just got this
thing
and and i think he he was trying to
express the fact that he just didn't
care he just didn't care about his
his status but for me he he did care
that car was every bit as much of a
status symbol for him
as the
you know the brand new mercedes um
four-wheel drives were for the other
parents it's just that he was playing a
different status game in his game
having a crap car is is a high status
thing the same as the aristocracy in
britain so you know if you're if you
remember the british aristocracy you'll
look down your nose at people who have a
brand new japanese
lexus or whatever they drive up beating
up land rovers and so
so it all depends what game you're
playing different different games
um use different things to symbolize
status and and
and so so that's how that game works
lots of people play the fame game lots
of people play the money game um but
other people don't you know if you if
you were if you were hanging around with
gandhi in india you wouldn't be playing
the the money game you you you you would
have got more status for living the more
simpler your life became the more status
in that group you would earn
it's so true i've played all those games
in my life i'm still playing many of
them
uh i'm not here to lie so that's
that's just what it is um and i think
really interestingly on that as well is
um one of the status games i was playing
when i was
a little bit well i say insecure but
clearly i'm still insecure if i'm still
playing status games status games now um
was how much designer stuff can i buy
and
champagne can i buy in nightclubs i
played that game between 18 and 24. yeah
and then when i actually got money when
i actually was successful
i actually saw louis vuitton as a
lower status thing so i just started
wearing all black and got rid of all of
my designer stuff
because i now think that it's a
different game yeah it's a different
game
yeah and so i don't now i have an
allergic reaction to anything designer
because to me
yeah it's weird i think it's low
standard i think in my head it's true
and in the book i write about this this
hilarious study where they figured out
because in the in the luxury goods game
the bigger the logo the lower the status
yes and they figured out that
i forget the exact measurements but a
certain amount of
um logo space um
you know like
half an inch
um
smaller meant you know 500 more on the
on the price and the most expensive
designer stuff has a logo on the inside
it does no logo on the outside and so as
a and and what that kind of speaks to is
that again
the whole world isn't one status game
there are kind of almost infinite status
games and people we're not particularly
we're not that interested in what people
outside like games think think of us
it's much more about what people are
playing the games with us think of us
and so you know in in my wife is the
former editor of elle magazine so it's
uh you know
so you know that fashion luxury world um
you know people signal to each other i
will see a handbag and it will just be
invisible to me what that handbag means
what the meaning of that handbag is but
the person the owner of that handbag
won't get the first [ __ ] why i think
about their handbag they're interested
in what's what what you know that woman
over there who knows about their handbag
nose and they'll know by the quality of
the stitching by a tiny little detail on
the corner of that bag that that is a
really good bag and that's what matters
because that's that's the game they're
playing a game with that person they're
not playing the game with me so i don't
care what i think it's so you know i
have this very unproven um
thought that just came to mind when
you're saying about the size of the logo
that when you're at the very when it
comes to luxury goods at the very bottom
of the status ladder you want the
biggest [ __ ] logo possible yes
you want it all over the garment and if
you think about certain like you know
people you know where they are in that
status thing they will have they will
wear a track suit
of that logo and then as you rise
financially or in status the logos you
say gets smaller and then it disappears
so if you look at billionaires they're
not wearing
jeff bezos is not wearing a louis
vuitton track suit
they have the yacht they're playing that
game yeah yeah how many feet is the
yacht but yeah super interesting
makes me wonder
do we actually really care about these
things do we actually really
um
we i i spend we spend our lives telling
ourselves that we want that birkin bag
we we really genuinely love the
lamborghini but do we do we actually
like the lamborghini or we do we just
just like what it's signaling about us
well i i don't want to over i don't want
to over um
kind of
i almost over promised the story like
like
i think there's a danger where you can
say well a lamborghini is 100 status
there's nothing else i think that's that
that's not quite fair in lamborghini
they're amazing machines and i've never
driven a lamborghini but i'm sure it's a
fantastic experience you know i i
you know i've driven sports cars a
couple of times and it's been amazing so
it's not just status like it is it's
incredible to have like a camera that's
like amazing photographs so so you are
you are getting something extra for your
money but it's but but but mostly i
think what you're getting is is status
that that's really mostly what you're
getting and it's worth it i mean i think
i i i don't want to forget that trap of
being condescending to status it is a
fundamental human need that we feel of
value
and you know if we're playing a high
level status game with lots of
lamborghini owners it's really really
hard to feel a value in that group so
you've got to work really hard um so
that's why a brand new lamborghini for
somebody playing that game will feel as
good as a
you know
as a dirt bike to somebody playing a you
know a game over there like
one might cost multiples more than the
other but it will feel just as good
because they're worried about they're
only really concerned about what the
other people in their
their game of thinking so so so yeah we
do care and and it's it's a good thing
because it's
that you know the book
does talk a lot about the negatives of
status pursuits but it also talks about
the positives of status pursuit i mean
civilization technology
that that's what you get um when people
want to pursue stages when somebody
wants to become the best technologist
the best vaccine designer the best um
um you know the best charity we want to
save the most lives that's humans at
their best and that's also status
pursuit but it's good it's positive
what is the
toxic downside of being addicted to
status though and and my sub question to
that is that is insecurity and sort of
a lack of self-worth a
predictor of being addicted to status
games
being human is a predictor of being
addicted to games we're all addicted to
status games and do you not think people
that would believe in that didn't that
were that were lo that were low status
in childhood in some contexts yeah are
those that then seek status most as
adults
um maybe but again again i do think that
personality comes a lot into play um
like anything some people are more
interested in the status than other
people like elon musk
is obviously incredibly interested in
his own relative status and that's a big
driver for him
um uh jeff bezos you know beyonce you
know these people um
are
are very highly attuned to the status
game and that's what pushes them pushes
and pushes them to work harder than i
will ever work
um
so i don't i don't necessarily think
it's about um low self-worth it might
it's probably to do with genetic things
like
extroversion agreeableness which is a
personality um
component if you're low in agreeableness
you're competitive it's that kind of
type a personality so
so so there's definitely a genetic
component to it uh definitely but
there's also you know
class comes into it uh people
on the lower socioeconomic groups have
much less access to status games so
so you know i think that's why
you know if you're a working if you if
you're a poor guy
raising a housing estate in stockwell
and you're only the only available
status games to you are
tesco's bakery
and this gang over here i know what i'm
joining you know it's changed the way
that i see
some of those issues that you know we
are we are programmed to
we are programmed to crave connection
and status and we will find connection
and status
wherever we can and so i and i i think
that explains
you know when people are joining gangs
it's not because they're naughty it's
not because they're bad people it's
because they're just doing what they're
designed to do but they're in an
environment where there aren't many
status games to play there's just not a
lot of options
it's interesting because when i i think
think of some of my friends that i that
i believe in my own
you know
ill-informed observation are addicted to
status
the ones that are really addicted to
status the ones that are really pursuing
it
are actually pursuing at the cost of
connection
and what i mean by that is my my richest
most successful friend that i have that
lives in a massive mansion in the middle
of nowhere because that's the place that
he could buy the biggest house and has
all the sports cars
um is is also the loneliest yeah that's
that's a really good observation i mean
status inc and connection they're
separate things so we we crave by you
know nature both of them we people are
tend to be happier when they're more
connected but status is a separate thing
and i think that's right i think that's
absolutely correct some people's that
people's dials are set i i consider
myself somebody who is relatively high
in need for status which is why i ended
up writing books for a living but i'm
really learning to find a connection i
don't really have much of a social life
i don't really want one you know i'm not
bothered particularly um so you know
everybody's dials are set in different
ways some people have relatively low
need for status and their relatively
high
need for connection and they're
surrounded by friends and they're
probably happier than i am i'm sure
they're happier than i am is there
instances where we can be too consumed
with status and that can cause us to
have
um adverse personal consequences
um yeah i suppose
okay so in the book i write that there
are kind of three general types of
status games that we can play
first game is the dominance game and so
the dominance game we share with animals
we've been playing dominance for
millions of years and they are what they
sound like they are they're about
aggression but also the threat of
aggression um
bullying
you know that kind of thing
whenever we
force somebody else to attend to us in
status that's dominance um there's
success games which is i think the best
of human nature um competence so when
you when you're thinking about
how do we become a valued member of our
tribe um back in the days when our
brains were evolving we could be the
best honey finder the best storyteller
the best hunter best finder of tubers so
that's how you're a value to your tribe
competence for being good at something
but there's also virtue um um you know
we we can play virtue games and so in
the tribe that means that you know the
rules
of the tribe you enforce the rules of
the tribe you know the rituals you
believe in the spiritual stories um so
virtue isn't just about being selfless
and kind and loving to the your tribal
members it's also about being an
enforcer
and i think you know there's no such
thing as a pure game that's the other
thing to kind of point out like like you
can see um
a boxing match as a dominance game it's
pretty clearly a dominance game but it's
also got a virtue element to it there's
some rules in boxing you can't just go
and kick them in the groin you know like
there has to be some virtue in there too
so you call that dominance virtue game
and i think that i think the worst games
i think the games that are most
destructive are what i call virtue
dominance games so a virtually dominance
game is one in which i i'm raising
status by enforcing rule but by
following rules and knowing the moral
rules the dominance um uh component is
i'm going to force you to do it so so
you know that's what you see on social
media a lot
those cancer culture mobs people
attacking each other for believing the
wrong things that's a virtue dominance
game um at their very worst a virtually
dominant game you know in the book i
write about the rise of the nazis i
write about
the find the final chapter which kind of
brings the whole thing together
is the story of the rise of the
communists and the soviet union uh from
the perspective of status and and you
know that that's also a virtue dominance
game
they're not interested in competence in
in success they're interested in you're
going to believe this and if you don't
we're going to punish you
yeah that's a lot of that going on at
the moment there's a lot of that going
on at the moment and i think a lot of it
is because
um you know trying to be kind of
open-hearted about it i wrote about this
in selfie and i wrote in in the status
game is that since the financial crisis
life has got harder especially for young
people
success get you know like it's hard to
get on the property ladder uh people are
leaving university with student debt
there's massive underemployment for
graduates we've got what they call elite
overproduction we're producing too many
smart educated people for the roles to
fit in it's it
you know
we're now entering a new recession
apparently so so
life is much harder for millennials and
gen zeds and it was for boomers and gen
x's so success games are harder to play
so what you i think what you're seeing
is online people people get status
wherever they can so they they start
playing virtue games instead
one of the alarming things you talk
about in this book is that um status did
i say that right yeah yeah that's the
english way i need to because i'm not
american and that will harm my status
attack me in the comments section
um
this idea that status games actually
have an impact on our health and
mortality that we will die younger
if we have lower status what evidence
have you have you got have you
got or found to support this idea well
there's lots of evidence um there's a
big a lot of it comes from this guy
called dr michael marmar who's just did
this incredible set of work which he
calls the whitehall studies so obviously
whitehall is the bureaucracy that kind
of runs that kind of takes the order you
know
the civil service that kind of works
with the government so it's an enormous
organization highly stratified and so
marmot um looked at um kind of health
outcomes for people on different levels
of that kind of hierarchy that status
game and found that the the the the the
lower you went down that status game the
worst health outcomes became so the
obvious thing is oh that's just because
if you're being paid less you maybe
can't afford the personal trainer you
know you're eating worse but it wasn't
that that wasn't that case at all
literally one rung down below at the
very top so still a very very wealthy
successful high status people had worse
health outcomes than the person at the
very top
so so it really did seem like
um the brain is highly attuned to where
we sit in a pecking order and the lower
the lower we are down in that pecking
order the more unhealthy we became
another set of scientists looked at this
in the in a laboratory
so they took a bunch of monkeys
um uh uh who um obviously like us very
hierarchical without a status games
and um they deliberately felt it's a
terrible experiment it's very it's
pretty awful but it deliberately fed
them a terrible diet of like fast food
like chocolate and crisps so they so
they ended up having a high level of
athletic plaque which is you know so
they they were getting clogged up
basically and vulnerable to heart
problems and so on
and they found that it was the same that
the lower you went down the monkey
pecking order
the more likely the monkeys were to die
of these heart related diseases because
of their bad diets than the ones at the
top and then importantly they
um conspired to change the hierarchy of
the group i don't know how they did it
but they changed them but they took out
the top monkey they changed the
hierarchy of the group
and um they found that the health
outcomes changed in lockstep with a
change in hierarchy so what if a monkey
went up they became less likely to die
and so so then you might ask what this
is crazy like why is this and so so the
closest answer that the scientists have
come there's a whole field called social
genomics it's a new field and social
genomics is all about how does our
social world affect the function of our
genes so you know we're social animals
our brains are constantly monitoring how
we're doing in the world what are our
levels of connection what are our levels
of status we have this status detection
system that's constantly monitoring our
level of status
and so so the idea is uh that uh when
the brain
registers that we
are you know dropping in status we're
not too high in status
it prepares ourselves it changes the way
our our genes work and our and the
actions of ourselves change in such a
way
um that it kind of prepares us for kind
of trouble
um so inflammation goes up
antiviral response goes down and so the
body changes in such a way that we
become more ill
there's a really um
a narrative in there which some might
deduce from hearing all of that which is
that your level of success relates to
your
health and this i'm going to say in the
really gruesome way which is the more
successful you are
um
the longer you you'll live
obviously there's loads of factors yeah
yeah if you're eating burgers and
smoking and exactly doing classy drugs
that's going to probably be a stronger
sort of determinant in your outcomes but
but generally speaking if two people are
eating the exact same thing if they're
living the exact same lifestyle in terms
of what they're consuming and the way
that they're living and the only
variable is their
level of success in a status game yeah
then they will be they're less likely to
die if they're higher up yeah that's
true yeah quite a bit
as you said there's so many confounds i
mean life is much more complicated than
that there's there's always other you
know it is true that people you know
smoke and don't smoke and and so on but
but but you know what marmite finds is
that is that if you take two smokers the
one higher up is less likely to die of
smoking-related disease than the than
the one lower down in the status in the
status game yeah whatever yeah
interesting yeah and one of the other
things that i wrote down reading that
book was workers at the bottom of the
office hierarchy have at ages 40 to 64.
four times the risk of death of their i
guess administrators means managers yeah
at the top of the hierarchy yeah that's
from the white hole studies yeah that's
part of what doctor's mental yeah it's
crazy so they're really significant it's
not marginal they're you know when you
when you
it will be marginal from one layer to
the next when you actually look at the
whole game it's very significant the
the difference is the health outcomes
from the top and bottom it's absolutely
mental i've never really considered that
idea before that
status is playing such a significant
role in my
biological situation
um the same is true for connection so
when we're lonely the same thing happens
the lonelier we are when we lack status
the same thing
we know we we have that our uh
information goes up antiviral response
goes down which is bad for us in the
long term and there's the same
with uh the social genomics people say
it's the same with loneliness which is
why loneliness is bad for our health too
the other thing that i found
particularly interesting was that um
when we lose our status the consequences
of that can be pretty morbid yeah and
that suicide is often the result of
people losing status and the speed in
which they lose their status yeah yeah
so so this is why i never believe the
jeffrey epstein conspiracy theories i
think he did kill himself because he's
just at this huge um drop in status it
just makes him incredibly vulnerable to
suicidal
thought and ideation so yes it's not
just drops in status it's especially
sudden drops in status makes us very
vulnerable um and also i found it was
interesting the research says it's it's
also being left behind so if we
if we stay still and everybody else
everybody around us accelerates that
that's that also makes us vulnerable to
uh potentially you know anxiety
depression and potentially suicidal
ideation that in particular is quite um
an alarming thought that if you're in a
group of five friends
best friends and four of the best
friends do really really well
professionally in their careers whatever
just because of the context in which you
you're existing
you might become depressed because your
forefronts did well and this in some
respects might explain jealousy
of course it does yeah i mean i mean you
know we we we've evolved to
um
want to feel of value but unfortunately
being of value is kind of relative
like if everybody is equally valued then
nobody's valued 200 million we're all in
the same level so you it's that i i
think that's what it can become quite
damaging
yeah and that's where life can become
quite exhausting especially in this kind
of highly um competitive neoliberal
world that we live in where everybody's
pushing pushing pushing to succeed
pushing to succeed you know it's true
you know i hate you
we hate it when our friends become
successful parts of us
are always going to because it kind of
devalues what you know what we have
you know it's just um an unfortunate
byproduct of the of the status game
you talk about how
we look
up to people who are like us yeah but we
also seem to be more jealous of people
that are like us yeah
because they because they are the the
clearest evidence of our own inadequacy
yeah it's that that was a really sort of
um um
kind of
naughty paradox for me to get my head
around when i was writing the book
and the closest solution i could come to
it was so when you look at um
how human social groups work
um there's a really amazing research in
america called joseph henrich who
studies this stuff and has written about
a couple of books about this
and
and he talks about how
how we learn and so so in those again
those groups in which we evolve which
we've sort of looked to to figure out
why we are like we are
what you'll find is that is is the is
that when you were growing up
you know young people look they identify
high status people from which to learn
and those high status people um are
going to be like them in some way
they're probably going to be the same
gender and they're going to have the
same kind of interests and you know that
kind of thing and so so this mechanism
switches on which is copy flatter
conform so you start copying their
behavior because the brain goes well
this person's high status i want to
become high status um so say if i want
to become high stages because i got to
do everything they're doing if i do
everything that they're doing oh you
know it'll work so it switches ons and
then we've got the flatter process which
is
i need access to this person i want to
be around this person to be able to
learn everything that they're doing and
you do that with you know flattery is a
good way of doing that it's like um you
know you're amazing i love this what a
great book what a great podcast you're
amazing businesses and then you know so
so we'll let people in who treat us that
way and conform you you do what you do
what you do what you're told you you
behave
and and so and so
you know you can you can you can think
about that when you think about
celebrities you know like i i i remember
when i was
seven or eight years old i was obsessed
with this guy called this guy nick
kershaw and i remember seeing him on tv
am and he was crossing his legs in a
certain way with his
ankle on his knee and his legs sticking
out and i just found myself sitting at
school in the same way as nick kershaw
you know so so like that my copper you
know my copy flatter conform
mechanism is switched on
so i i think that's i i think that's how
kind of fame works i i think it's that
we we we see people who feel like a
piece of us but a highly successful
piece of us like that person's like me
but amazing and so so these very ancient
evolved mechanisms switch on even though
we're pretty never going to meet that
person they just switch on and we become
and so you know you'll notice that um
people read the same books as their
idols they dress the same way as their
idols they might even
you know i find i mean i'm embarrassed
about it but i think it's probably very
common when when i've watched a stand-up
comedy special and i've loved it i'll
find myself talking like that comic the
next day like using their inflections a
bit um it's just kind of weird you know
or laughing like them you know so so
generally speaking we're quite envious
creatures we don't like high status
people and but there's a very narrow
class of people that we identify with
and those are the people that feel like
super successful versions of us like we
we relate to them we identify with them
and and that's when that
very evolved ancient mechanism switched
on which i call in the book copy flatter
conform
yeah it's so interesting
much what you've described as well as
explains influence marketing and why
it's so effective why why you know
if you look up to someone they can sell
you anything absolutely yeah that's what
the whole industry is based on
um the other the other point that you
talk about in the book around the role
that status is playing which really
alarmed me and made me ponder quite a
lot was about how
our pursuit for status is more important
than our pursuit for money when we've
kind of addressed the money topic and
how you know many employees would would
rather accept a higher status job than a
pay rise yeah a different job title yeah
that's that's pretty alarming yeah it's
it well it is but it's not that
surprising when you think about the
evolution of the brain we haven't
evolved to crave money because money
hasn't been around long enough
we've evolved to create status and money
is just one way that we can measure
status but there are loads of other ways
we can measure status so it doesn't you
know it doesn't have to be
money-based you know so and as you said
though that was a quite a major study i
think it was 15 000
people in the uk that they surveyed and
found that most would accept a diff a
higher status job title over a
modest pay rise yeah so instead of you
know
i've got jack sat over there he's the
producer director of this podcast so
jack what's your job title right now
um
director slash producer okay so if i
change jack's job title to
ceo of the podcast yeah
versus giving him one thousand pound pay
rise he'd probably take the ceo of the
podcast
yeah yeah yeah
but he's also smart thinking because
because you know
when we're judging other people's status
it isn't just how much money they have
in fact the money's often invisible the
the the title says a lot so if you were
to you know make jax you know he's my
podcast ceo he's more likely than to go
on and get a better job somewhere else
higher status more money because of that
bump in status so it's actually the
instinct is correct it's a smarter move
to take the title than the grand so i
could reduce his salary by half
no yeah i think
that's something i think we're so
sensitive to um reductions in status
that is there we'll never fly
that's interesting
um you talk about the cues as well
within status games that we we kind of
look for what are those four cues
yeah this is this is again joseph
hendricks's work where he looks at um um
you know how do we identify the people
that we want to copy flatter conform um
so there are various cues um one of them
is um uh with they think on success cues
so so in um
the hunter-gatherer tribe it might be a
hunter has a big necklace of teeth one
tooth from every creature that he's
killed um you know so
so that's why we have jewelry these days
because it's it's a success cue
and
it's amazing when you read about the
detail
because the you know the brain is some
neuroscientist called it has his status
detection system so we are constantly
all of the time
uh monitoring our environment for
status queues and you know playing that
game and and so so we're constantly
monitoring other people's body language
um we we can measure someone's relative
status versus uh you know submissive
versus dominant in 43 milliseconds
that's how quick when we see somebody we
we measure how
dominant or submissive they are in in
terms of status so that's how quick it
is so so so we're looking at things like
um
successful interruptions in conversation
the more successful interruptions you
make the higher status you are like
we've all been in situations maybe you
not for a while where you're trying to
get a word in edgewise and everyone's
just everyone's just like maybe in a
family situation and you just think oh
[ __ ] it you know i have here smorgan on
the podcast so i can get a [ __ ] word
of hedge rates with him
but that's but that's that's actually a
perfectly valid point he sees himself as
higher status than you yeah and so he
and so and so both of your
games subconsciously were playing a
status game and and so so we are um we
so that's another way we we're also
measuring another cue is how other
people are attending to that person so
if we notice lots of people are
attending to a person we will
automatically assume they're worth
attending to and so what's interesting
um joseph henry writes is that is that
these effects were designed
to work in small groups of people
because that's how we we evolved in very
small tribes they weren't
evolved to um
operate
in in a global environment of modern
media in the internet so you get these
feedback leaps where lots of people are
looking at one person so more and more
people start looking at that person then
they get reported in the press and then
more people start looking at them and
they call it the paris hilton effect
because i think when they figured out
what was going on paris hilton was the
big why she famous person but you might
as well just call it the kardashian
effect or whoever the latest person is
that
every that happens to be really famous
and then no one can quite work out why
it's because
it's a feedback loop once you
lots of people start looking at that one
person everyone just piles in and
because their brains are receiving they
must be high status they must be worth
attending to if everyone's attending to
them people attend to them and then you
know you've also talked about how their
their health outcomes would be better
potentially as well so should success
queues go up their success queues go up
you know it sounds like a wonderful life
to live
so should we all start pursuing
status well no we uh well we i again i
say we we already are but but i think
you know
another way that all this research has
made me understand the world a lot
better is that when we look at very high
status people really rich wealthy
successful people
half our brain is just jealous it goes
out lucky them and we imagine have this
brilliant life and they're so happy and
everything's wonderful but with the
other half of our brains we know that's
not true because when you meet very rich
and successful people they're often not
happy
[Laughter]
you're right yeah exactly there's
suicide there's alcoholism there's
workaholism you know they're like
they're not happy the marriages don't
last so
it it it's made sense of that to me it
and that's tha
it's actually quite a nice understanding
that it the the there isn't this this
hierarchy of happiness where the richer
you are
the happier you are because we're all
playing individual status games so you
know those people playing high-level
status games the millionaires the
billionaires the elon musks
they're competing with
the people immediately around them
they're competing like elon musk is
competing with jeff bezos and tim cook
so they're no happier than the people at
school who are competing to be the best
well i say no happier that's the general
i mean i don't know but but but but you
know the higher you go the harder that
game becomes
so so so you know that's taken away a
lot of that oh wish i was this i wish i
was that yes i'd love a yacht you know
but still you know i'm not naive anymore
to how how difficult and punishing that
life can be at the very top because
you're not competing with
me anymore or the people down there or
you know or or even above me you're
competing with people they're competing
with the people who they're playing
against and they're all highly
successful highly motivated
um uh incredible individuals it's become
really interesting this whole um space
race
yeah richard branson jeff bezos elon
musk exactly you go really you all
really care about
exactly exactly but the other thing to
say about that is and this is again a
half change i mean i'm a lefty i've
always been a lefty but this book has
really opened my mind to the idea that
actually we do benefit from these people
not just in the obvious ways they they
hire a lot of people they give you know
people get meaning and purpose from
their jobs they people get to live a
life and pay their mortgage from their
jobs
they pay taxes that keeps the you know
that keeps the countries running so
they're they're they're doing all that
but also with the space race they're
competing because they're playing a
status game that's obvious but but
science and technology benefits from
that too i mean i mean i don't you know
that there will no doubt be a number of
innovations
that that are hugely useful to humanity
that come as a result of
this um you know this space race or
races like it amongst these highly
motivated
top level players
chapter 29 of this book you you kind of
you talk about how we can
advance
in the status game status game factor
again
and the seven rules of the status game
um how how do we advance in the status
game and what do you mean by advance do
you mean win
no because you can't win i mean that's
the thing i think the brains the brain
has this story that we live by where
where
and stories can take happy endings and
happy ending is if i achieve this then
i'm going to be happy and again
it's weird because we know that's not
true when we've lived a bit of life
because
you know
but we still kind of believe it if i get
this if this next book
sells 100 000 then i'll be happy and
it's like i know that's not true but um
so so so you you don't ever win it
that's an illusion that's the
storytelling brain you know just giving
you a bit of a lie to keep you motivated
i i think there are there are various
ways that you can succeed in the status
game um you know some kind of are quite
practical i think i think one of the
most practical is that
is this amazing revelation that status
is more valuable than money to most
people
and it's free like we have status to
give and you can save money as i've just
shown you
you can get call him a ceo and you can
go
pay him half it's unbelievable
i wish i'd known this earlier
but we can but we know but but we
so we have loads of opportunities in our
lives to um to give status to to to our
employees to the people around us and we
often don't
and you know and so so i think that and
and that feeds back in a kind of
real politicky
kind of slightly cynical way is if we
are generous with status people are
going to want to be around us and
they're going to want to work with us
and and and and some of that status will
wash back so so i think you know don't
treat status as if it's a limited
resource in the business context i think
there's a really it's not in that final
section but one of the other sort of
light bulb moments for me in the
business context
was this difference between um uh
competition and rivalry
so when you first think about
competition and rivalry in business you
think that's the same thing but it's not
so competition is bad um and and rivalry
is good so
so when i'm talking about competition
i'm talking about a corporate structure
like enron so that's the example i used
in the book so enron famously had their
rank and yank system where the top i
think it was 15 got promoted i think
they were judged that justin at least
twice a year everybody in the company
got judged um the top 50 got promoted
the bottom got fired and the middle were
just [ __ ] terrified so that's
competition so so competition is is a
sense of all against all you you go into
work and it's a
[ __ ] war and and you've got to grab
and you know and i think that that's
when you end up with extremely toxic and
ultimately potentially corrupt corporate
cultures because status is very hard to
come by
um
and um
so that's what you want to avoid and and
you know it's thought that like a very
moderate amount of competition is quite
good to motivate people but it very
quickly goes wrong
um the alternative to that is rivalry
now rivalry is is healthy and a massive
motivator and rather than being all
against all rivalry is one against one
so that's one individual against one
individual or one group one team against
another team or one organization against
another organization and rivalry is
characterized by um having this status
competition that's characterized by lots
of near misses and skirmishes so you can
think about apple and microsoft had a
period where where there were great
rivals and and that rivalry kind of
pushed them on and in the book i tell
the story um of the true origin story of
the iphone which is
quite amazing and it begins when steve
jobs to draw his wife was friends with
somebody from microsoft and she would
have regular parties barbecues and so
this microsoft executive this unnamed
microsoft would come to the barbecue and
um be bragging to steve jobs and and one
day he was bragging to steve jobs saying
um we've solved computing you know it's
over for you guys we've figured it out
we've got these tablets with these
styluses they're going to change
everything and then um
the next day the monday steve jobs comes
into work furious because his rival
microsoft is is dragging their faces in
saying we've solved computing and he
says let's say
let's show these [ __ ] pricks how it's
really done it's not done with stars
it's done with fingers that's how it's
done and that became the ipad which well
that became the iphone well first it was
the ipad but they released the iphone
and then it re-emerges the ipad and as
um scott falstal who was the guy that
told that story said it was very bad for
microsoft that steve jobs ever met that
guy but that's the true origin story of
the iphone this device that's changed
the world is status and rivalry this guy
from microsoft rubbing steve jobs facing
it at a barbecue so that's healthy
that's good well not good for microsoft
but that's that's what you want to be um
in a corporate sense in an
organizational sense you want to be um
you want to be encouraging rivalry and
not competition
interesting
i've always tried to make sense of my um
my love of rivalry
and i've always i've always wondered if
it was a toxic uh flaw in me or because
it seems to be such an unbelievable
motivator i'm so i'm so i've always said
competitive but now i'm hesitant to say
that word but i'm always looking for a
rival yeah even you know i have 10
friends we're in a fitness competition
and um every month we hand out oh these
fake awards there's gold silver and
bronze yeah and
four days out i won gold last month and
then four days out from this month my
friend good friend of mine he's managing
director of one of my companies olivia
onsherv he starts talking [ __ ]
to me and i was so happy he did because
i realized that in those last four days
of the month i was gonna do i was gonna
work out three hours four hours a day to
beat him and it was and it's almost i
reflected on what i saw in michael
jordan's documentary where michael
jordan would it would seem look for
rivalries he would so much so that he
would make them up and when they went
and asked the other person if it
happened they'd go now that didn't
happen but michael jordan had created a
rivalry in his head
to motivate himself there's actually a
clip on youtube called it became
personal with for me which is just a
compilation of michael jordan repeatedly
saying a story that might
might not have or might have happened
and then saying it became that's when it
became personal with me and then it
shows him slam dunking on that person or
winning another title or whatever this
constant search for rivalry is as a
motivator that's fascinating that's
exactly right yeah that's that's
fascinating and and so that that that
description you say if somebody who's
highly deserved constantly looking for
rivalries i think that's that that's
correct
and i i also think it's it
it's a mistake to think
is it healthy or like is it toxic is it
a good thing or a bad thing i think i
think
one of the things i try not to do my
books is to categorize what's good and
what's bad it just does because because
in real life reality it's usually a
trade-off most things are trade-offs and
so yes in lots of sense if you're
playing your success games um it will be
it's a good thing it's a massive
motivator it was for steve jobs it was
for michael jordan it sounds like it is
for you but that doesn't mean it's a
hundred percent good thing
if you start losing that's going to
become
a
source of a lot of misery for you so
i think we often make mistakes when we
try to figure out whether something's
good or bad because i think the reality
is that most things are trade-offs
you're completely right it is a
trade-off and go working out for three
four hours a day was not a good idea
yeah it was a significant cost to that
with my my relationship with my sleep
with you know with my productivity so it
is a trade-off and i guess it all
depends what your objective yeah your
objective ultimately is
you've written um
a number of books now many many books
more books than i think i'll ever write
in my life because um i i think i
struggle to to
to write books and you know you find
yourself in a place in life now where
you're
47 47. it was difficult to find find
your age online
i had to go back to an article i think
where you said you were 38 and do the
math so i wasn't sure if you're already
saying but um
what else are you are you in search of
in your life personally
what else if i i've asked this question
in maybe the last i don't know 10
episodes to my guests but if if if your
overall happiness was a um a recipe
consisting of a set of ingredients what
are you looking for personally now in
your life to
fulfill that happiness recipe
that's a very good question so i i think
that one other thing one of the things
i've done recently is i've um i've not
started yet but i've i i've i it's going
to be happening this month is i'm just
going to start volunteering
to a charity
because i feel like
as we've already spoken about one of the
things i don't have is much connection
like i've got a great marriage but
you're outside the marriage i i i don't
really see people that much
and i feel like because i don't have
children i don't actually do anything
for anyone else so it's going to i felt
like i was becoming quite a selfish
life everything was just about either my
part of my dogs so i i'm obsessed with i
don't do anything for anything else so i
i figure that's that that's a bit of a
hole in my life so that's why
i'm going to start volunteering um
um if i've got to be interviewed by this
charity but assuming that goes well so i
think i i think that's a whole and and i
do um i i do want to sort out the
connection side of things like i've
started having semi-regular meetups with
some old school friends recently which
has just been
an absolute joy to to see these people
after you know so long and
i kind of i kind of in my head start
telling the story it was me that had
failed on my exams and was
a total disaster but it was amazing to
see on there with all these lots of
that's a lawyer and there's also
successful people we all failed our
exams it was just a really bad school
but we all kind of succeeded um
regardless of that um so so that's been
a that's that that's been
really fun and i've had to kind of
um yeah so so i think it's i think it's
moving the dart on connection that
that's what i'm missing
we have to become more and more
intentional about that connection i
think especially i feel like men
probably more so definitely yeah you
know and it's one of the things i've
said to my five friends is i've said to
them you know as we get older when it's
a birthday or when there's a wedding
make sure we all go because it's going
to become increasingly this there's
gonna become increasingly more excuses
as to as to why we shouldn't go or we
can't go we live further apart we have
families yeah
and you really i feel like as a man you
really have to fight for that connection
as you age and so yeah i mean i i kind
of i kind of really do believe that
there are basic biological differences
between the genders on average you have
to say generally speaking it was huge
overlaps of course we're more like than
we are different but i think
on the average i think you know
men and women are you know there are
differences and i i do think that one of
them is
how we manifest socially
i think
you know um women are much better
instinctively
at the group yeah you know
whether that's um politically
or um
uh
in a friendship context they're just
they're just there just seems to be
men just seem to
have an instinct for going it alone yeah
and women seem to have an instinct for
the group
together going it together that's a
lovely way of putting it yeah and um and
and and i think that you're right i
think men especially have to fight
against that i think that's why the
suicides are so much worse for for men
and and i and as the suicide expert i
spoke to herself he said
the solution isn't that men should be
you know should be more like women um
because that's you can't change biology
but but but i think you're right i think
especially with the social connection
thing we have to push ourselves a bit
harder and i always notice with the
social stuff it just seems to always
happen where when you've got a social
appointment
coming up you think oh what did i say
yes to that for but then ask a hundred
percent of the time we think i don't
want to go but then when you go you go i
had a great time this is amazing i
should do this more often and that's
also 100 of the time it's so weird
that um we we've seen so
like men especially seem to be so bad at
predicting how much we're going to enjoy
a social occasion
on that point with a suicide expert you
know because much of the narrative i do
here regarding male suicide is that we
we just need to talk more and we're
often
with that argument often comes the the
sub point that if you look at how women
are open and communicate with their
social circle with their yeah you know
their friends and they they say i'm
feeling this i'm going through this blah
blah blah blah men don't do that so men
need to do more of that yeah what did
you learn from your conversations with
that suicide expert well his view and
mine too um
is that i don't think i i i like sure
talking helps but but but but
just saying to men you should be more
like women is not that helpful and
actually what we need to do is figure
out what are men like
and um
and
um start
trying to develop solutions that are
specifically designed for men i just
think saying to men that you should
learn to cry
i haven't cried for
years you know it's like it's it's just
not um
it's not fair on men it's not smart
there needs to be more work done in how
can we actually help men in a male
friendly way
you know um i i i i think that's i i
think that's um
the way to go
what are men like
what are men like because you know you
said we have to figure out what men are
like yeah
cater to their unmet needs
i'm guessing in a in a in a way that
kind of they can relate to what is that
well again like you've got to be very
careful but but by by not generalizing
yeah
there's a huge variety in what men are
like you know you know
but but but just to sort of underline
the fact we're talking sort of generally
speaking here my sense is that
as as i said before women are much
better in your great words at going
together but whereas men tend to be mine
but pretend to be more by instinct going
alone
and and like everything that's a
trade-off um and and the negatives are
um
uh that we are you know we are less good
at talking to
other people and and sharing our kind of
burdens i think that
i think i've got no scientific evidence
to back this up but my my impression is
that that that male identity
um
is focused more around success personal
success
so i think i think that's why you see
lots of male suicide in middle age
because in middle age
men and siblings in their bodies they
their careers might grow into a whole
their um relationships with their
children might start going wrong they
might get divorced and divorce you know
you know
uh
yeah it's not good so so i i i think
that that's where men um particularly
might get into trouble
when when men feel like i'm not a
success
i'm not looking after my family i'm
failing in my job
it's that sense of being a failure
um
i
yeah i think i think that's very very
hard for men
the suicidal ideation you describe in
selfie was that linked to those reasons
yeah i think i think it's connection and
status
for me i mean the the last time it
happened really badly was when i moved
back
from i lived in australia for four years
and did quite well in australia as a
freelance journalist
but came back with nothing no job
because i was a freelancer and so yeah
and then for a while i just thought i
was gonna have to start doing day shifts
you know uh in magazines like it was bad
i just felt like i'd
everything had gone wrong and so that i
think that was very much connected to um
uh status i mean i'm very bad because in
the in the book i recommend
um playing lots of games playing
multiple games i mean the science is
pretty clear that
um the more status gains people play in
their life the more sources of status
they have the more groups they belong to
the more stable their personality the
happier they tend to be and as i said
earlier on i just i tend to do writing
that's kind of what i do that's partly
the selfish reasons for the volunteering
i i want to have another source of
status
to protect myself against the inevitable
getting older
thing
when we realize that status games are
like a comparative thing so um
you know
being a journalist if there's a
journalist that's the editor and is
doing amazingly well
then and you're underneath and then
there's somebody at the very bottom of
the the ladder and the person at the
bottom of the ladder is going to be
lower status just by measure of
comparison so does that mean that in
some regard in the society we live in
that is based on status there will
always be
someone at the bottom that is feeling
that way
because just by a measure of comparison
there's going to be someone else who is
making them feel inadequate or like low
status yeah there's always going to be a
hierarchy you can't remove the hierarchy
from the human it's how we process
reality i mean when you go into any sort
of situation if you've me if you if
you're introduced to five strangers you
know this you know like you have a
conversation within minutes you'll start
getting a sense of who's up there who's
down there and it'll be body language
it'll be who's got the jobs who's got
the clothes you know your brain's just
calculating you can't stop it it's gonna
happen and and and you can't stop it
because everybody else is doing it to
you too you know so you know that that's
something that other people give to us
as well is that is our sense of status
we sense it from other people um so
so so so there will always be people um
you know at the bottom in inverted
commas but there are a few things to say
that sounds grim but there are a few
things to say about that the first thing
is that um
again we all play individual little
games so so it isn't as though the
cleaner in the office feels like they're
competing with michelle obama because if
they did they would just walk they'd
just throw himself out the window that's
not how life works that cleaner is
comparing themselves to the other people
in their life people they work with
their families their cousins they you
know
so they're not feeling
horrific because they're not the king of
thailand so that's that's not how it's
working it's not life isn't that brutal
two we have amazing imaginations
and you know we're very good at buffing
ourselves up and finding ways of of c
you know seeing more of value
and i think in in a healthy organization
as i say in the book you can go to a
meeting as the lowest status member of
the organization in that formal status
game make a fantastic contribution and
leave feeling like the king of the world
like the best person in the room and
that and if that's a healthy
organization that's how you'll be made
to feel too you'll be like oh it's
brilliant that's amazing so so so even
within those kind of formal games that
we play in life we can still
have a encounter an experience in which
we
actually feel hugely of value
um
it's it's
so there's also that to say so and
there's also you know life is a
never-ending game
as long as we're not suffering from
depression if we're a mentally healthy
person we're a little bit optimistic
we're backing ourselves a bit you know
that's that's what people are like you
know i'm i feel like i'm going to
i have the capacity to achieve x y and z
you know so so so yes
um there will always be people at the
bottom but but a they're probably not
going to stay there for very long
because the game's so fluid and b that
that doesn't mean that they're condemned
to a life of constant misery and torture
and and as you said earlier they can you
know they might also play for a sunday
league team and be top of the league and
yeah captain of that team or they could
be religious i mean their religion is a
status game and and that's a virtue game
as of you know a a and it's often a
healthy um virtue game you know in a
religious game i've got to follow the
ten commandments and to go to the church
and do whatever i've got to do and then
i become a high status christian or
whatever and then
and that's
you know that's a big journey i've
gotten i used to be very angry and
hostile about religion because of my
background but but now i see that
religion although it's not for me
it's hugely valuable to people um
because it gives them a status game to
play
and meaning and purpose and exactly i
was the same i was religious up until i
was uh 18 very religious household and i
rejected it quite passionately for many
years until i stopped caring about it so
i'm just like do what you like
exactly so which is a funny arc we kind
of go through where yeah the aggression
against it and then the acceptance of it
um
we have a closing tradition on this
podcast where the previous guest asks
the next guest a question okay right in
the direct diary so i get to read it now
jack keeps the diary until this point um
the question left for you is
when it all gets too dark
what helps you find the light
when it all gets too dark what helps you
find the light i mean creation i i mean
that's that really is true if i'm
feeling depressed
um i just
i've got this it's quite cheesy but i've
got this little
i've got this little saying i say to
myself in the head which is the only way
out is art and and so if i want to feel
good i'll go
and
do some work do some writing and if i'm
proud of it it'll sort of pull me out of
it so that that's kind of what helps me
see the light my
my my art and how does that relate to
the status game book status game
massively because i i feel good about
myself you know if i this is my game
writing and if i feel like i've written
something good
i feel like there's hope
and it kind of gives you a psychological
status boost absolutely yeah because we
you know we we we have this imaginary
audience in our heads we're not just
being judged by other people we're being
judged by ourselves so so yeah i think
that's hugely important
well thank you incredibly illuminating
and it's given me a tremendous amount of
food for thought you know when we do
this podcast i'm always selfishly
looking for um ways that i can make
changes to my life or understand the
decisions i'm making so that i can make
decisions more in line with my values or
more in line with where i want to go and
i think you're this book in particular
the status game i pause every time i say
it because i'm scared to get it
the status game yeah this book in
particular the status game um
is is one of those that isn't
tremendously illuminating because it
explains so much it's almost like it's
turning a light on in a
huge room that i didn't even know was
there
um and really revealing to me what what
the forces are that are controlling
um much of my decision-making for better
or for worse it's not to say that i will
abandon a band try and abandon those
forces because i don't actually believe
i can i think that's who i am but being
more conscious about them which i think
is exactly what this book allows you to
do as they relate to your relationships
your personal life your business is i
think something that we can all benefit
from so thank you for writing such an
amazing book and thank you for writing
all of these amazing books but this one
in particular
um is my favorite the status game came
out last year i believe um yeah just
down paper back two weeks ago on people
back two weeks ago and i've had a lot of
people specifically because you've had a
few conversations with some friends of
mine really raving about this book so i
highly recommend everybody checks it out
um of all these books i love them all
but this one in particular is my
favorite i can't be more excited to see
what you write next fantastic thank you
for your honesty as well not everybody
is so willing to be so open and honest
and i think there's something so
um
so important because
it's huge it's human and it's truthful
about the way you're willing to be
honest about your own struggles in your
life and the things that you're
searching for as it relates to
connection and those things that is
we're all we're all going through the
same battles and hearing that from you
as well i think is particularly
important so thank you thank you thank
you for your amazing questions too
steven i had a really good time thank
you
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast crafted are
brands that sell really meaningful
affordable men's jewelry and i've been a
crafted customer i think for about three
years now the piece of jewelry i wear
the most i want to introduce you to the
pieces and why i wear them is this sand
timer unsurprisingly and the thing for
me about sand timer is it's probably the
most clear reminder that our time here
on earth this finite and when you live
in such a way where you can literally
see your time pouring away and you
realize that it is scarce and that we're
not all here forever you start to make
better decisions you stop worrying about
pettiness and trivialities that consume
our lives i always have this crafted
sand timer around my neck as a reminder
of that and this is why i wanted crafted
to sponsor this podcast because i can
use their meaningful jewelry
every episode to deliver a meaningful
message my girlfriend came upstairs
yesterday when i was having a shower and
she said to me that she tried the heel
protein shake which lives on my fridge
over there and she said it's amazing low
calories you get your 20 odd grams of
protein you get your 26 vitamins and
minerals and it's nutritionally complete
in the protein space there's lots of
things but it's hard to find something
that is nice especially when consumed
just with water and that is
nutritionally complete and that has
about 100 calories in total while also
giving you your 20 grams of protein
if you haven't tried the heal protein
product do give it a try the salted
caramel one if you put some ice cubes in
it and you put it in a blender and you
try it is as good as pretty much any
milkshake on the market just mixed with
water it's been a game changer for me
because i'm trying to drop my calorie
intake and i'm trying to be a little bit
more healthy with my diet so this is
where heel fits in my life thank you
hill for making a product that i
actually like the salted caramel is my
favorite i've got the banana one here
which is the one my girlfriend likes but
for me salted caramel is
the one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you